Most of what the SCP Foundation contains are
things you would rightfully prefer to keep
locked up. After all, not many people want to be
torn to shreds by SCP-096, tortured by SCP-106,
eaten by SCP-082, or driven mad by the
sheer power and evil of the Scarlet King.
Most SCPs are so cruel or dangerous that a run
in with even a cute little teddy bear could
spell your doom. But what about the other side
of the coin? What about the SCP objects you
don’t just want to avoid, but actually have
in your possession? To use as you see fit?
That, my friends, is exactly what we’re here to
discuss today: The SCP Objects you’d actually
want. No hidden catches, no nightmarish side
effects, no curses or strings attached. Think
of it almost like an anomalous skymall catalogue -
these are all the SCPs you never knew you wanted,
but would happily break into an SCP
Foundation containment facility to obtain.
Speaking of breaking into places, let’s
start our odyssey of desirable anomalies
with SCP-005. Have you ever forgotten or lost
your keys and been locked out of your house?
Or maybe you’ve wanted to get a backstage pass
to your favorite concert without spending a dime?
Heck, ever wanted to rob a bank or steal a million
dollars in gold from Fort Knox? Don’t worry,
we’re not here to judge, in fact, we’re going
to tell you how to make those dreams come true.
What you need is The Skeleton Key. As you can
probably tell from the name, the skeleton key
is a normal, if a little old-fashioned-looking
key that can open literally any lock on earth.
The White House? No problem. The Pentagon? Piece
of cake! Buckingham Palace? You can stroll right
in and try on all the Queen’s finest jewelry.
Though of course, if you have no interest in
becoming a master infiltrator and instead just
want a little more convenience in your daily life,
the Skeleton Key also makes life easier by
making you only need one key for your house,
your car, your bike lock, any lock at all!
Think of all the pocket space you’ll
save, the possibilities are endless!
Speaking of “endless”, the next item on the
list gives a whole new meaning to the phrase
“all you can eat.” Are you feeling
hungry? Are you part of the strong 95%
of the human population that loves pizza?
Then buddy, you’re going to love SCP-458,
also known as The Limitless Pizza Box. If the
name alone hasn’t sold you, then trust us,
it’s going to get even more appealing. The anomaly
is a large-sized pizza takeout box from the Little
Caesar’s pizza chain, and not only can this
box produce a truly endless quantity of pizza,
it also has an intuitive psychic
connection with whoever is using it.
Are you a devotee of Chicago-style deep dish?
You got it! Do you prefer more of a cheesy,
New York style slice with a little parmesan
sprinkled on top? Order up! Or maybe you’re
a real traditionalist, and like it pure Italian -
no cheese, with a sprinkling of olives. Paisano,
this box has got you covered. If you love pizza,
then SCP-458 is a must-have for your kitchen.
So let’s say, hypothetically, you’ve just eaten
six pepperoni pizzas from SCP-458. Dishes are
piled high in the sink, and you know they need
to be cleaned, but you’re in too much of a food
coma to get up and do anything. If only you could
just ring a little bell, and summon someone who’d
happily do all those stupid chores for you.
But alas, such a thing is impossible, right?
Well you’ll be delighted to learn that this is
very much possible with SCP-662, also known as
the Butler’s Hand Bell. With a simple little ring,
you’ll summon the hyper-helpful British butler Mr.
Deeds, an entity who literally lives to serve.
From doing your laundry to giving you foot rubs
to assassinating that one jerk at your office who
always steals your pudding cups from the fridge,
Mr. Deeds will endeavor to complete almost any
request within the realms of physical possibility.
If you’ve ever wanted to lie back
and have someone else take care
of all those pesky responsibilities that
make up the big to-do list that is life,
then SCP-662 is your must-have
anomalous ticket to freedom.
But maybe you don’t need a supernatural
butler to do everything for you.
You’re self sufficient, you take pride in
doing things for yourself. But you feel a
little down, and you could really use some
encouragement from someone close to you.
It’s times like these when you could really
use a few words from the father who is no
longer in your life to get you feeling
confident again. If this applies to you,
then you’ll definitely want to get your hands
on SCP-348, also known as A Gift From Dad.
This wholesome soup bowl appears to be a spiritual
conduit to a loving fatherly figure, producing
the ultimate comfort food that will cure minor
ailments and leave you with a sense of happiness
and peace. Its effects may not be as amazing as
some of the other big ticket items on this list,
but it’s definitely one of the most
feel-good SCP objects out there
and sure would be nice to have on
hand for the days when you need it.
Speaking of feeling good, what feels better than
being in love - especially when the person you’re
in love with is just perfect for you, and
loves you back just as much? The problem is,
in a world as big and complicated as ours, who
knows where your true love is waiting to be found?
If you can feel yourself longing for the love of
your life, then you need SCP-2203, also known as
Find the Right One for You. This device is a
standard “love tester” machine, the kind that
were a lot more common in bars a couple decades
ago. But this is a love tester unlike any other.
When you use the machine, it doesn’t give you a
rating from “cold fish” to “casanova”. Instead,
it dispenses a small card with a name and address
on it - which just so happens to be the name and
address of your true love. It even features advice
on how to initially approach and woo the potential
person of your dreams. For the socially awkward
and hopelessly romantic, this machine feels
heaven-sent. Just remember, once you’re actually
in the relationship, it’s up to you to be a good
partner if you want to make it last - SCP-2203
can’t help you with that part, we’re afraid.
Of course, an important part of being a romantic
partner, or even just a good friend, is being
attentive to the other person’s needs. But to
meet those needs, you first need to understand
them - and wouldn’t it be great to know someone’s
deepest desires without having to go through the
trouble of actually asking? Allow us to introduce
you to SCP-978, also known as the Desire Camera!
This simple polaroid camera allows the user to
peer into the very hearts of their subjects.
All you need to do is take a photograph of them,
and the resulting polaroid picture will reveal
whatever their deepest desire happens to be
- whether it’s a trip to an amusement park,
a new tie, or to reconnect with
their estranged father, Keith.
Is it a little creepy to pry into someone’s most
private thoughts like this without them knowing?
Absolutely. In fact, it’s super creepy. But hey,
what they don’t know won’t hurt them, right?
Maybe all this violating the privacy of your
closest loved ones has worked up a powerful
thirst in you, but you don’t just want any
old cup of joe. Maybe you want to have the
exact cup of coffee you had at a now-closed
diner in 1995. Or maybe you want to know what
a liquid dream tastes like. Or perhaps you
just need a cup of antifreeze for your car,
and really don’t feel like going to the hardware
store to get some. If this describes you,
then you need to get your hands on SCP-294,
deceptively known as The Coffee Machine.
We say “deceptively” because this anomaly
is so much more than a coffee machine.
With a little pocket change and the
electronic keypad connected to it,
you can order any liquid you desire, even things
that don’t traditionally come as liquids. No
matter your thirst, you can satisfy it with the
help of SCP-294. Of course, there is the possible
downside of ordering something dangerous or
deadly and then drinking it, but frankly,
that would be more your fault than SCP-294’s.
Remember to read the warning labels, kids.
Maybe you’ve ordered an alien energy drink from
SCP-294, and it really isn’t sitting well with
you. You can feel your liver withering away inside
you and even if you call an ambulance, you’re not
sure that it’ll get here in time to save you.
It’s starting to go dark - is this the end? No,
because lucky for you, you took
the time to acquire SCP-2295,
also known as The Best Bear - a name that
this plush creature has more than earned.
You see, this bear is the world’s smallest
yet most competent trauma surgeon.
If ever someone collapses with organ failure
within two meters of this magnanimous little bear,
it will create a perfect, functional organ
from nearby materials like yarn and string
to replace the broken one, and then perform a
flawless, life-saving surgery on its patients.
If ever you worry your organs are on the
fritz, then you’ll be glad that you can count
SCP-2295 among your personal possessions.
Also, even when your organs aren’t failing,
nobody can deny that it’s nice to have a
cute little teddy bear around to cuddle.
But what if you don’t want a little bear or a
magic butler to solve all of your problems? Maybe
you want to be a little more self-sufficient,
and gain the knowledge and skills vital to live
the life you want to live. If this applies
to you, then you’re going to adore SCP-5094,
also known as Miss J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse. This
software which comes on a CD-ROM is the ultimate
find for the life-long learner! Anyone who has
the program can be personally tutored by Miss J,
the perfect digital teacher, on almost
any subject they can possibly imagine.
Want to become an expert in advanced
thermonuclear physics? Want to be able
to memorize every single one of Shakespeare’s
works to the letter? Want to know everything
a human being could possibly know about
cats? Have no fear, Miss J has your back!
With her trademark intensive courses, she can
turn novices into experts in just a few days,
leaving you feeling enriched by the knowledge
you’ve just been exploring. If expanding your
mind and your horizons on a regular basis
with the best teacher in the world sounds
like a dream come true to you, then SCP-5094 will
be an SCP object you’d kill to get your hands on.
Metaphorically speaking, of course, Miss
J would never condone violence after all.
After a hard day of hitting the books, or
computer screen, you’re going to need a snack.
But just not any snack. You want one that’s out of
this world, or maybe even out of this dimension.
It’s time to pay a visit to SCP-261, also
known as The Inter-Dimensional Vending Machine.
This machine randomly generates exciting snacks
and drinks from all across the multiverse
including Fruits of the Loom, a package of three
pieces of edible underwear in fun, bright colors,
and Rat on a stick which is…
well, exactly what it sounds like.
And finally, what do you get for the person
who has everything else? The best gift of all,
the gift… of life. There are still
plenty of diseases that even the
SCP-Foundation has not been able to
cure, except with one extremely rare,
and extremely special anomalous item
- SCP-500. Also known as The Panacea,
the SCP is a bottle containing a small number of
pills capable of curing any ailment known to man,
from Alzheimer’s to the Flesh That Hates. When it
comes to healing, there is no equal to SCP-500.
And considering you’ll be
drinking interdimensional
soft drinks and eating truly
disgusting amounts of pizza,
it’s never a terrible idea to have a
cure for cardiac arrest laying around.
And there you have it, folks! A list of the SCP
Objects you actually want. The hardest
part is going to be breaking into the
heavily-guarded Foundation containment
sites to get them in the first place,
but hey, we can cross that bridge when we get
to it. Which of these objects do you think are
worth the risk of getting shot by a Mobile
Task Force for? Let us know in the comments!
Now go check out “The Eye Pods -
SCP-131” and “SCP-1609 - Remains
of a Chair” for more SCP objects you
wouldn’t mind having in your life!